hey this is presh tallwalker
a circle contains two chords a b and c d
that do not intersect
chord rs intersects both of these chords
it intersects chord a b at the point p
and it intersects the chord cd at the
point q
if ap is equal to 12
pb is equal to 20
cq is equal to 10
dq is equal to 24 and pq is equal to 14
what is the length of the chord rs
this is adapted from a problem on the
2021 bangladesh mathematical olympiad i
think moon tahina from bangladesh for
the suggestion
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try and when you're ready
keep watching to learn how to solve this
problem
[Music]
suppose that pr is equal to x
and qs is equal to y
focus on the chord a b
notice that p s is equal to 14 plus y
by the intersecting chords theorem we
have ap multiplied by pb
that's 12 multiplied by 20
is equal to rp multiplied by ps
that's x multiplied by the quantity 14
plus y
let's now focus on the chord c d
from here we will have r q is equal to
14 plus x
we then have cq multiplied by dq that's
10 multiplied by 24
is equal
to sq multiplied by qr
that's y multiplied by the quantity 14
plus x
let's now focus on these two equations
first we'll simplify the left hand side
each left hand side is equal to 240
then we will distribute on the right
hand side
from here we will subtract the second
equation from the first equation
we will then cancel out the xy terms
the resulting equation is 0 is equal to
14x minus 14y
this means x is equal to y
from here we will substitute back into
the first equation
we have x is equal to y so we'll
substitute for y
then we will distribute to get a
quadratic equation
we'll subtract 240 from both sides
and then we will factor this equation
it'll be very easy to factor we'll get
the two linear terms are equal to x
minus 10 and x plus 24. this means x is
equal to 10 and x is equal to negative
24 are solutions to this equation
since x is a length we want x to be
greater than or equal to 0 so we'll
eliminate this second solution
therefore x is equal to 10.
this means that y is equal to 10 because
x is equal to y
finally we go back to our diagram
rs is equal to 14 plus x plus y
we have x is equal to 10 and y is equal
to 10 therefore rs is equal to 14 plus
10 plus 10 which means rs is equal to 34
and that's the answer
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on youtube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve the world's problems one video at
a time
you